foreign
misremembering this but when I read your
book one of these studies that seemed to
hop out to me maybe I was having a fever
dream so please correct me but it was
looking at sleep deprivation at
different points after initial
acquisition of
knowledge so you had students who were
studying
and this may have been alcohol related
as well so you'll have to clarify for me
but one might think sleep before
learning important yes of course sleep
say the night after learning important
yes but as I recall it was something
like three days later if you interrupted
the sleep
whether by deprivation or alcohol
that you subsequently saw lower recall
scores something like that am I
inventing this no your memory is
pinpoint accurate so your sleep is not
perhaps quite as bad as well yeah you're
right so we've done these to these and
there are perhaps two cities that speak
to your point one of the studies
you have people learn some information
and then you deprive them of sleep the
first night after learning
but then you don't test them you give
them all of the recovery sleep that they
want on a second night and a third night
and then you test them
and what we find is that the memory
recollection is still impaired out on
day five
so in other words if you don't sleep
within the first 24 hours after learning
you lose the chance to consolidate those
memories so sleep for memory is an All
or Nothing phenomenon and you know if
you're not snoozing that first night
you're losing and no amount of recovery
sleep on the second or the third night
was going to salvage the process because
it seems as though that there is a
selective time window of opportunity for
consolidation and if you miss it
unfortunately it's gone so in that way
sleep isn't like the bank that you can't
accumulate that debt and then try to pay
it off at a later point in time that was
the first study then there was another
study done by Carlisle Smith a great
memory researcher
we didn't do the study but I I'm so
jealous because it's such a brilliant
study he was looking at different forms
of sort of Creative Learning which we
know is more dependent on REM sleep
learning facts textbook information and
saving that stuff that's about deep
non-rem sleep and we can speak about the
mechanisms when it comes to integrating
and associating the information as we
spoke about that's more about REM sleep
so he did a very clever study he knew
that one of the major consequences of
alcohol's disruption on your sleep is
not just that it sedates you not just
that it fragments your sleep but it's
very potent at blocking your dream sleep
and the reason is because of the
aldehydes the metabolic byproduct and
something called
acetaldehyde is the main reason that
your REM sleep is demolished by way of
alcohol and he was very interested in
this idea because we knew at the time
that REM sleep dreaming REM sleep
dreaming was associated with this type
of creative memory so he took a group of
individuals and he separated them into
about four or five different groups
and everyone learned this information on
the first day which required them to
sort of create it was actually very much
like learning a novel language it was an
abstract analogical language almost like
learning a computer code that's
completely foreign to you and it's not
just about learning the individual
pieces it's understanding the
grammatical rules of this big picture
structure associative
so they learned it on day one and then
out on day seven they tested those
individuals so they learned it without
any alcohol in the system and then they
were tested seven days later without any
alcohol in the system but here was the
clever twist one group across those
subsequent six nights they slept
normally with no alcohol the second
group the first night after learning
that information they got them
essentially just to the point of
inebriation to about the point of being
blood alcohol illegal you know point
zero eight percent and it was body
standardized dose across individuals so
you had one group the control group the
second group they got a little bit tipsy
on night one and then the subsequent
night they were alcohol-free then there
was a third group of individuals who had
they learned on day one sober then they
had natural sleep the first night no
drinking then they had natural sleep the
second night and no drinking and then on
the third night that's when they dosed
them with alcohol and then again
everyone was tested on day seven and
what did they find firstly relative to
the group that got a full night of good
sleep every single night across the six
nights their memory was still there it
was present
but in the group that had alcohol dosed
on the first night there was a greater
than a 50 percent loss of their memory
out on day seven because of the impact
of alcohol on night one on REM sleep but
the frightening part was the Knight 3
group
so the third group they were very good
they said okay I've been let's say it's
a student you know I've been learning on
Wednesday and I've got all this
information I'm not going to go out with
my friends drinking on Wednesday night
because sleep is important for memory
and then I'm not gonna go out on
Thursday night because I've just learned
all this information but then on Friday
surely my memories are now safe I'm
gonna go out I'm gonna have a few drinks
oh Contra because even alcohol on night
3 caused almost the same it was about a
40 deficit in memory and what that tells
us is not just something about alcohol
it tells us that the sleeping brain is
still processing and consolidating and
digesting information three days after
the act of learning itself so yeah it
was a great study and you've got a
fantastic memory yeah that's the one
that blew me away and I was like oh my
God it's tough isn't it it's like please
come on I know why does biology have to
steal all the fun